hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game number eight on our series of the
2021 world chess championships being
held in dubai between madness carlson
the reigning champion and jan nepo the
challenger now up until this point we're
halfway through it's the best of 14
series and we've had six straws and we
had one victory that victory was the
last time menace crosman played the
white pieces two days ago in game number
six it was the world record for the
longest chess game in a championship
series just under eight hours
136 moves so madness carlson looking to
extend his lead going into the break
tomorrow and young nepo looking to fight
back definitely does not want to go down
two games
going into the break so madness carlson
in game number eight starts out with e4
e5 and then f3 knight f6 so getting into
the petrov defense ops for a different
line than we've seen in the past so
instead of the main line of knight takes
here on e5
d6 and the knight comes back to f3
instead we see madness carlson going for
the d4 line knight takes here on e4
bishop d3 attacking the knights pawn to
d5 defending the knight and now the
knight takes up here on e5 so you can
see kind of a interesting position both
sides have their pawn on the d-file
supporting the outposted knight
knight to d7 madness carlson decides to
go ahead and exchange so bishop takes
here on d7 knight to d2 and then we have
the exchange here and then bishop to d6
so symmetrical line from both sides here
and
kind of makes you wonder how they're
going to progress from here is it going
to be a slow drawlish game or is one of
these sides going to try to open things
up cass on the king side from madness
carlson and then h5 was not expecting
this from nepo that says
you know what hey if you're going to
castle i need to strike and so h5 says
exactly that typically not going to play
h5 and then castle yourself on the king
side could try castling on the queen
side at some point uh but really the
only thing we know is
nepo is looking to attack and this is
the start of that and so h5 was exciting
to see because you know pretty much
going to see some fireworks after h5
queen 2e1 check and then king f8 so we
start to see the idea of not castling on
the queen side
wants to get his king to a safe square
which it is right here on f8
but then he can maneuver his rook around
the board with h6 centralizing if he
wants to get the queen involved at some
point and then bring his work over here
to e8
from madness crossing the standpoint
decides to go ahead and play bishop here
b4
attacking this bishop uh queen comes to
e7 we do see the bishop take here and
then queen takes d6
queen d2 rook to e8 and then rook over
here
e1 says yeah if you want to exchange you
absolutely can rook 2h6 just getting
involved into the game since it can't
castle on the king side this is really
the only way for this rook to get
involved into the game and then queen g5
so madness carlson getting pretty
aggressive with his queen here
pawn c6 just solidifying this pawn chain
protecting this pawn d5 from the queen
here so that's definitely good to see
and then the rook takes here on e8 and
you don't want to just take down here
with your rook because then all of a
sudden magnus carlsen can just recapture
with his own rook and he's essentially
gained a tempo here we have the exchange
magnus carlsen controls this file right
here
instead a little bit better to play pawn
c6 because now after the exchange bishop
takes then magnus carlsen has to use
another move to bring his rook to e1
it's just not recapturing here on e1 but
at the end of the day we do see the
rooks come off the board and then magnus
carlsen controls this e file which is
better than this rook right here h6 you
typically want your rooks to control
open files or semi-open files this work
on h6 is not really doing either of
those it's trying to get involved into
the action but right now it's not doing
a ton also manuscript has a much more
active bishop here on d3 compared to
this light square bishop on e8 it's
playing defensive mode it's blocked by
both of the pawns so all in all
manuscripts and definitely has a better
position
nepa recognizing he does not have the
advantage plays queen f6 saying hey
madness carlson hey buddy hey let's just
go into the break go ahead and exchange
off the queens it's going to be fine
don't worry about it madness crossing
not today my friend we are playing queen
e3 we're not really looking to trade off
material he is looking for blood and to
press the action he's also threatening
queen takes on e8 that would be
checkmate so definitely have to worry
about that
bishop d7 now it's just defending this
square here on e8 so pretty good square
here h3 just to make sure hey there's no
shenanigans that there's no back rank
mate or anything like that also does
stop some of the threats if the bishop
were to come down g4 at some point but
the main thing is to make sure that
there's an additional square this king
can go to if it ever needs to escape
pawn c4 we do see the exchange right
here
and then a pretty interesting move so
magnus carlsen has the isolated pawn on
the d file and then if you start to look
at
where black can really go from here
has to worry about the threat that this
king is under
does not actually see the threat and
instead plays the move pawn to b5 now
this is a
big mistake i'm curious if you can
actually see
the air on board if you want to pause
see if you can find the best move for
manish carlson
but the threat really is queen a3 this
is czech and it's also attacking this
pawn
a7
and you can see after the king moves
because can't come to the e file it's
being attacked by the
rook here on e1 so after the king comes
to g8
then the queen takes here on a7 and hey
yeah you could now take our bishop but
we'll just take your bishop as well so
jan nepo loses a pawn in material
and typically at the highest level we
haven't seen these crazy big mistakes
now in the last game game number six or
madness crosston won yes there was an
exchange
there was queen for two rooks getting
into the end game very complicated to
see if that was a mistake now at the
very very end uh you know 130 some odd
moves in
yes there was a mistake by the queen but
these small incremental mistakes we
don't really see nepo uh make those but
he loses a pawn here and fabiana
carhuana giving chess commentary
throughout
said that he went on tilt because after
that move
he then played the move queen d8 and
this is actually another mistake and
things start to build on himself really
what he should have played is bishop
takes here
h3
now queen takes f7
check and then queen takes
rook up here e8 probably the best move
after the king moves away then we see an
exchange here and then bishop to f5 yes
black is still down in material that
mistake here on a7 is not going away but
all of a sudden madness carlson has his
big pieces off the board that queen is
definitely off the board and you've
started to
trade down some material and he's only
down a pawn so that's not as bad as how
play continued because after the queen
comes here to d8 then we see the bishop
come back b3 madness crosston recognizes
okay i won that exchange and now i get
to hold on to all of my powerful pieces
let's not exchange anything else let's
see if i can use these pieces to my
advantage
we see rook to d6 attacking this pawn
rook up to e4 defending that and then
bishop e6 we do see the bishops come off
the board here rooks come off the board
and now it's a game of okay magnus
carlsen is up a pawn
he does have the centralized queen right
here there's three pawn structures for
yon nepo gonna be difficult for him to
hold on to all of those especially with
a centralized queen from madness carlson
so this is looking like a very very good
setup for madish carlson and getting
into the end game there's just no one
better out there now it's just a matter
of execution
nepo now plays queen to a5 and we do see
in exchange said yeah if you want to
attack my pawn on c6 that's fine i'll
take
your pawn here on f2 after queen e1
check king moves and then queen f2 yes
he has the threat of queen to g3 but the
king's just gonna come back
but we do see
queen taking here on e6 with check this
is extremely important because what he
doesn't want to do is perpetual check
meaning yeah nepo plays queen g3
and then the king comes back to let's
say g1 and then he can just come down e1
and just keep doing that over and over
he wants to avoid that so magnus carlsen
he's trying to
slowly take pieces
always make sure that he's in a position
where his queen is extremely active
attacking his opponent's king and at the
same time make sure that his opponent
cannot perpetual check so a lot of stuff
going on for madness carlson not too
much to think about for
mere mortals though that many times can
lead to a drawn game king h7
queen down to e4
check always attacking king comes back
to g8 and then pawn
b3
queen takes here on a2
and then queen e8 this is check also
taking this material over here so
getting into the clear in game and
magnus carlsen is up two pawns in
material gonna be very difficult for
black to hold on to this and get a draw
out of this queen two f2
queen over here e5 as we talked about
before uh just stopping all the threats
that black has now you can't even play
the queen to uh g3 now because they were
just being exchanged and then it would
be pretty easy for madness carlson to
push up the pawns so queen to b2 and now
the idea is protect both of these pawns
right here he needs both of the threats
on the board
to have just an easy end game
after king g8 he plays queen d3 also had
the option of just taking on h4
giving up the b-pawn but i do like his
approach that says you know what i'm not
too worried about this pawn on h4
instead
let me play queen d3 and just hold on to
both of these pawns because it's so
difficult to try to protect both of
these pawns uh for for black to really
attack both of those at the same time
and so yeah i really like the move of
queen to d3
queen f2 from yonepo and then c3 this is
not only defending both of these pawns
but also is always looking at the square
here on e1 if the king moves can play
king 2 g1 and so that protects the
square here on f1
but really the threat is the queen
coming to g3 at some point and then
coming back to e1 and check and so the
queen on c3 is also defending that
square on e1
queen 2 f4 check
king down to
g1
you can see
not many threats though the queen also
can't come to c1 that's defended as well
so madness carlson covering all of his
bases here king 2 h7
queen d3 check pawn d6 defending
queen to d1 so this is defending the
entire first rank here also still
defends both of these pawns right here
and also allows for this pawn to start
pushing up the board so really really
good setup from madness carlson queen e3
sure king over here h1
pawn g5 the pawn starts to push forward
anytime you ever pass pawn you always
want to find ways to push it and the
queen doing a good job of defending that
pawn g4 so nepo recognizes he can't
attack with this queen the only other
option is start to exchange on the board
but then h3 queen two f3 and at this
point says yeah if you want to trade off
your queen if not i'm gonna take this
pawn right here and then you're going to
have no threat on board yeah nippo
realizes
it is game over and he resigns now
sometimes you've asked you know how
would this game continue you're
typically going to see queen 2 c1 you
can't just trade off because then you're
just down so much material there's no
way to stop it so you have to keep your
your queen on the board even though it's
losing
king h2 maybe
pawn takes
queen two
e4 yeah that this pawn could could
absolutely fall but yeah let's go ahead
and attack the king right now king two
uh g7 and then king takes right here and
then up three pawns in the in game
there's just no way for black to stop
this eventually pawn or white's going to
be able to promote one of these pawns
and easy victory so game number eight
we had some fireworks janepo tried on
the king side of the
board push forward with h5
hey props to him for trying something he
could have easily just had a drawlish
game both sides you know had a
symmetrical lineup and it did not look
like magnus crosstalk was going to be
able to break through so he tried but at
the end of the day
did play a mistake lost a pawn went on a
little bit of tilt lost another pawn and
at the end game magnus crossing made
zero mistakes played it flawlessly and
so after game number eight madness
crosston is up two full points they do
have a day off tomorrow
coming back after that young nepo has
the white pieces and surely we're going
to see something besides the ry lopez
anti-marshall he's tried it every single
time before four times in a row i don't
think he can try it's not going to work
so i i'm expecting fireworks the rest of
the way these players know that
we can't have any draws now or madness
crosston will win in a short order so
really excited to see this victory
madness carlson is playing exceptional
chess if you're not enjoying
these games the in games that he's
playing just flawless i mean that the
dude is an absolute machine um i don't
know what to say but it is it is fun i'm
i'm curious from everyone that's
watching how you think this is going to
is madness carlson just going to win uh
a game or two in the next few and then
this is over does jan nepo have any
chance at all can he come back can he
get a victory uh in the next series so
we have day off and then two two games
can he win one of those to give himself
a shot or is this thing over so let me
know in the comments below what you
think of the series and if you think
there's any shot of yannepo coming back
but thank you guys so much for watching
this video hopefully you enjoyed it and
i'll see you guys in the next one